bonjour nous sommes le 20 septembre
bienvenue pour le 7 8
l actu voici quelques uns des titres qui
seront développés en ce vendredi trois
mois de prison avec sursis c'est la
peine requise ce matin par le tribunal
correctionnel de versailles contre
l'homme qui s'était opposé aux contrôles
policiers à trappes de sa femme voilée
sur place pour la rédaction nous
retrouvons yolaine thorez
le parc zoologique de thoiry demande au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
de revoir sa copie concernant la hausse
de la tva au 1er janvier
elle passera de 7 à 10% et solar a
forcément à des conséquences
il ne sera pas candidat en mars 2014
l'ump gérard larcher à la tête de sa
commune de rambouillet depuis 30 ans a
décidé de ne pas se représenter
il passe la main vous entendrez tout à
l'heure ses explications
à l'image du jour à présent elle est
signée claire cambier à magny les
hameaux une quinzaine de parents
d'élèves de l'école maternelle corot a
occupé durant la matinée les locaux afin
de dénoncer une situation de sureffectif
depuis la rentrée ils réclament la
création d'une quatrième classe mais
pour l'instant le nombre minimum
d'élèves ne seraient pas atteints pour
l'inspection académique
selon un représentant de la fcpe la
question du budget se pose également
et vous le voyez ce matin les parents
ont eux mêmes créé une classe fictive
avec leurs enfants et ils annoncent être
prêt à continuer ce mouvement
une information qui concerne les motards
à l'occasion des 24 heures du mans moto
un relais motards calmos est en place
jusqu'à samedi midi à hauteur du péage
de saint-arnoult sur l'a10 un relais où
le peut trouver à deux boissons chaudes
ou encore de quoi à manger mais surtout
obtenir des recommandations en matière
de sécurité routière et dans les
yvelines aux utilisateurs de deux roues
sont décédés depuis le début de l'année
on reste dans le domaine des
déplacements routiers avec une image
depuis le début de la semaine et en
vigueur ce nouveau permis de conduire au
format carte de crédit que vous allez
apercevoir une uniformisation européenne
qui permettra de lutter contre les
fraudes grâce à une puce les anciens
papiers roses sont voués à disparaître
mais pas avant 2030 3l les modalités de
remplacement vous seront adressées
suite progressivement ces cartes seront
en vigueur inutile de vous rendre dès à
présent préfecture le 18 juillet dernier
un contrôle d'identité d'une femme
voilée dégénérait t'attrape son mari à
ce serait est interposé avant de s'en
prendre violemment à la police placé en
garde à vue des émeutes ont suivi c'est
donc un procès sous haute tension qui
débutait aujourd'hui à versailles devant
le tribunal correctionnel on retrouve
pour la rédaction lionel torrès michael
qui rit 21 ans a été auditionné ce matin
ici au tribunal de versailles le 18
juillet dernier le jeune homme se serait
violemment opposé aux contrôles
d'identité de sa femme entièrement
voilée
c'était d'ailleurs le point de départ
des violences qui ont secoué trappe et
pendant trois nuits
selon la version des policiers le jeune
homme aurait frappé l'un d'eux
violemment au visage avant de le serrer
à la gorge
les trois policiers affirment également
avoir reçu des insultes des faits
contestée par le prévenu
resté très calme tout au long de
l'audience michael qui rit a jugé
illégitime le contrôle
on rentrait avec nos courses nous
faisons de mal à personne at il dit le
procureur a requis 1000 euros d'amendé
et trois mois d'emprisonnement avec
sursis pour le prévenu le délibéré lui
est prévu le 8 novembre
si le jeune homme n'a pas fait de
déclaration à l'issue de l'audience
l'avocat des fonctionnaires de police a
souhaité préciser que le contrôle
d'identité de la femme voilée s'est
déroulée dans le respect de la loi
jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est la loi
de la république française qui
s'applique en france on ne touche pas
aux fonctionnaires de police et que si
on laisse la porte entrouverte aux
manoeuvres des gens qui sont ici à des
fins politiques pour instrumentaliser la
religion y aura des incidents de plus en
plus grave car de police alliance a
réagi après la réquisition du procureur
en réclamant trois mois de prison avec
sursis et 1000 euros damende le syndicat
espère que le juge ira au delà de ce
réquisitoire pour le syndicat des peines
planchers doivent être appliquées pour
que tous les individus auteurs de
violences envers les agents de la force
publique soit puni le délibéré sera donc
rendue le 8 novembre à 21h septembre
journée mondiale de la maladie
d'alzheimer on estime à un million le
nombre de personnes atteintes
elle pourrait être deux fois plus
nombreuses dans les dix prochaines
années on va écouter la directrice du
groupement médico social géré handicap à
magny les hameaux
la qui intervient auprès des patients et
de leur entourage elle était l'invitée
de ce journal jeudi soir on a recensé
huit cent cinquante mille personnes
touchées par la maladie ou par une
maladie apparentée
l'association france alzheimer elle
estime qu'il ya effectivement un cas
toutes les deux minutes qui est avérée
alors après effectivement on parle
effectivement de 230 mille cas
diagnostiqués tous les ans alors osez
vous le mondial au niveau mondial
effectivement on a des chais beaucoup
plus important forcément 35 millions
aujourd'hui 66 millions d'ici 2030 donc
une progression qui est lié beaucoup
aussi à l'allongement de la vie dans les
yvelines on a des dispositifs qui sont
un très bon maillage de ces dispositifs
qui sont très présents
je parlerai de la filière psycho
gériatrie qui est porté par l'hôpital de
plaisir qui était assez exemplaire et
qui comprend effectivement tout un tas
de dispositifs qui permettent dès qu'il
ya suspicion d'accueillir les personnes
de pouvoir ensuite les orienter vers les
dispositifs adaptés
je parlais tout à l'heure effectivement
l'hôpital de jour qui va permettre de
pouvoir faire des examens complets
neuropsychiatriques de la personne et
puis d'orienter ensuite vers les
dispositifs qui conviennent
l'association espoir à tchernobyl basée
à saint quentin en yvelines oeuvre afin
d'apporter une aide humanitaire et
médicale aux personnes contaminées suite
à la cac
mastrov nucléaire elle lance
actuellement une collecte de fonds afin
de financer à l'opération d'une petite
fille et biélorusses paulina elle était
d'ailleurs déjà venu en france vous
voyez sur ces images à l'occasion d'une
voyage d'un voyage qui étaient destinés
à ces enfants qui ont subi cette
catastrophe
cette petite fille pauline à doit subir
en france plusieurs opérations de la
phrase l'hôpital necker annonce près de
25000 euros de dépenses nécessaires sans
compter les frais de transport et
d'hébergement
vous pouvez contacter l'association
directement sur son site internet ou au
numéro qui s'est affichée le syndicat
fsu et les enseignants de trappes
toujours remonté invités par la
municipalité pour un bilan sur la
rentrée ils n'ont pas hésité à faire
part de leur mécontentement la nouvelle
réforme des rythmes scolaires est selon
elle mal organisés à la porte du stress
de la confusion au sein et des familles
la première adjointe au maire les a
reçus elle s'est engagée à faire le tour
de l'ensemble des écoles de la ville la
municipalité les a invités pour faire le
bilan de la rentrée les enseignants de
trappes très remonté en ont profité pour
s'exprimer sur l'organisation des
nouveaux rythmes scolaires
leur constat est sans appel selon eux la
situation actuelle apporte stress et
confusion au sein des familles
nous ce qu'on souhaiterait c'est
qu'enfin les acteurs terrain soit
entendu par la municipalité et que les
choses ne se passent pas comme elles se
sont passées depuis le début finalement
reçu par la première adjointe jeanine
marie les enseignants ont mis sur table
tous les dysfonctionnements qui l'ont
observé depuis la rentrée trop
d'horaires différents manque de locaux
ou encore manque d'organisation
l'adjointe évoqué des incompréhensions
des deux côtés elle s'est engagée à
faire le tour de toutes les écoles pour
observer l'organisation de la nouvelle
réforme
pendant ce temps le maire lui a reçu les
directeurs d'école la nouvelle gare de
saint quentin en yvelines vient d'être
inaugurée avec 25000 usagers par jour
sans rénovation importante depuis 1975
les locaux étaient devenus plus que
vétuste les aménagements extérieurs vont
se poursuivre jusqu'en 2017
anthony rech patrick jacques de dixmude
pour les précisions
les élus locaux découvre la nouvelle
gare de saint quentin en yvelines la
salle des pas perdus est enfin doté
d'une signalétique claire l'espace a été
déclarée zone et les usagers peuvent
désormais acheter des billets transilien
ou grandes lignes sans chercher leur
chemin ou point de vue de l'affichage
beaucoup mieux c'est vrai qu'au début
quand je suis arrivé à acheter
complètement paumé c'est clair que même
au niveau infrastructures rien à dire
c'est super on a implanté des nouveaux
panneaux d'information pour les trains
pour indiquer d'où partent les trains et
la formation vraiment sur le trafic qui
ont aussi contribué à faciliter la
gestion des feux dans cette gamme la
gare saint-quentinoise n'avait pas connu
de rénovation importante depuis 1975
avec 25000 usagers par jour le lifting
de la station était devenue vitale
on a refait le revêtement de sol les
plafonds qui ce qu'il y à la sécurité
l'éclairage la signalétique l'ensemble
des modalités de circulation verticale
escalators on a mis à niveau le parc des
ascenseurs les travaux de réaménagement
de la salle des pas perdus s'élève à un
million huit cent mille euros financés à
50 % par la région ile-de-france et à
50% par la sncf à l'extérieur la rue
joël le theule et l'avenue de la gare
sont encore en chantier à l'horizon
2017-2018 la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines pourrait voir sa passerelle
totalement réaménagé pour donner un
autre accès aux quais et que pensez vous
de cette nouvelle la gare ce sont vos
impressions que nous sommes allés
recueillir avec ce micro-trottoir allait
beaucoup mieux il c'est vrai qu'il ya
quelques années situe dans un très
mauvais état et c'est vrai que
maintenant aller super franchement je la
trouve bien et surtout la balle nouvelle
escale à tort je le trouve pas mal c'est
plus facile d'aller vers les clés c'est
pu fonctionner là et c'est beaucoup plus
agréable
trouve assez facilement on attend juste
que les travaux à la sortie soit finie
quoi c'est plus lisible
wei a déjà beaucoup plus de ja avant il
n'y avait pas de resto il y avait pas
tout ça est au poil vous de l'affichage
beaucoup mieux valait couleurs
l'agencement comment ça a été organisé
le design on a vraiment envie de vue d'y
venir
les villes doivent se constituer en
intercommunalité d'ici la fin de l'année
et le schéma proposé par la préfecture
des yvelines n'est pas du goût de tous à
l'instar de la ville des
clayes-sous-bois qui ne veut pas se
regrouper avec plaisir et villepreux
intercommunalités trop petit trop
coûteuse estime la maire véronique côté
millard elle souhaite saisir un cabinet
d'avocats catherine sultan avant la fin
de l'année les villes doivent se
regrouper en intercommunalité un dossier
parfois simples parfois épineux c'est le
cas aux clayes-sous-bois la préfecture a
arrêté son schéma et a intégré la ville
dans une intercommunalité à trois
communes avec plaisir et villepreux
ce n'est pas du goût du premier
magistrat la ville des classes se trouve
obligé c'est faux parce que c'est une
première en france contre sa volonté
contre la volonté du conseil municipal
de rentrée dans cette intercommunaux
théâtre commune c'est pour ça que
généraux fut simple c'est un périmètre
trop petit affirme véronique côté
millard l'élu udi s'appuie sur un texte
de loi en cours d'examen qui stipule que
demain la loi va inciter la création
d'intercommunalité pour des bassins de
deux cent mille habitants
il faudra donc totalement revoir la
copie pour la mère des clayes-sous-bois
c'est de l'argent dépensé pour rien on
nous demande d'ici la fin de l'année de
créer une structure à trois avec
éventuellement des transferts de
personnel etc et il faudra dans le même
temps la démonter parce qu'elle va
devenir obsolètes avant d'être d'être
créée puisque cette exigence
d'économie l'intercommunauté à 200
milles
ce ne sera posée d'ici la fin d'année
2014 donc gros problème pour la pour les
habitants du club parce que c'est une
fiscalité sera une fiscalité
additionnelle sans aucune contrepartie
hélas le troisième problème sa femme de
gouvernance cédé que trois ces deux
contre un donc ça c'est difficile
ensuite de pouvoir regarder une certaine
autonomie sur les projets comme pour la
mère des clayes-sous-bois la logique
serait de se tourner vers
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
la villa va saisir un cabinet juridique
pour attaquer cet arrêté de périmètre
intercommunal et ainsi suivre les traces
d'aubergenville qui avait aussi déposé
un référé contre le schéma proposé par
le préfet après l'inter communalité de
la métropole du grand paris un projet de
loi a été présenté cet été à l'assemblée
nationale afin donner de donner vie à ce
nouvel ensemble une nouvelle lecture est
prévue au sénat le 4 octobre l'union des
maires des yvelines attend d'ici là des
modifications puisque elle craint une
perte d'indépendance des communes sur la
gestion des transports du logement de
l'aménagement du territoire elle nous
avons demandé au président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines ce qu'il en pensait le nouveau
projet qui a été adopté à l'assemblée
d'un meilleur projet que le premier
voilà que deux éléments majeurs fait en
sorte que des deux parts département le
plus riche paris et hauts-de-seine soit
plus étroitement lié à au val de marne
et la seine saint denis mme par une
bonne chose pour la solidarité et aussi
pour traiter les questions de logement
sans pour autant créer une strate de
plus dans notre mille feuille
institutionnel
voilà ça c'est bien après effectivement
autour de ce noyau fort de plus de six
millions d'habitants il faudra les
intercomités des pôles métropolitains
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer de
travailler ensemble sur un système
multipolaire c'est le sdrif qui
insistait multipolaire et pour nous
notre système système multipolaire paris
saclay est un élément majeur de ce
système multipolaire de la région ile de
france 34 plan de reconquête
industrielle celle annonces du
gouvernement et de son ministre du
redressement productif énergies
renouvelables tgv
du futur industries du bois font partie
des priorités avec des objectifs fixés
pour rivaliser avec les autres pays pour
lancer ce plan baptisé la nouvelle
france industrielle
arnaud montebourg fleur pellerin encore
benoît hamon trois ministres étaient en
cours en début de cette semaine au siège
de cassidian la filiale d' eads deux
marchés plus spécifiquement ont été
évoqués la cyber sécurité et le
développement est du réseau 4g claire
cambier et jonathan vilma le ministre du
redressement productif annoncé la
semaine dernière le lancement de 34 plan
de reconquête industrielle
le but rendre nos secteurs innovants
plus concurrentiel sur le marché mondial
ce lundi arnaud montebourg a voulu
prouver que ces plans d'actions sont
déjà en marche
au programme une visite avec d'autres
membres du gouvernement au siège de
cassidian à elancourt filiale d'edf
tous défendent et bien la prendre les
sauveurs des ingénieurs spécialisés dans
deux secteurs clés le développement des
réseaux 4g en tête et la cyber sécurité
nous investissons là où nous pouvons
obtenir les créations d'emplois l'art de
la guerre
comme disait tous les stratèges
militaires c'est de concentrer nos
forces sur les points forts et non pas
les disperser sur nos points faibles
les partenariats public privé sont donc
mises en place investissements notamment
en recherche et développement et
évolution de la législation dans le
numérique on évoque le nombre de 150
mille emplois créés ou sauvés et plus de
15 milliards d'euros de valeur ajoutée
générée bon c'est formidable booster le
développement d'affaires en particulier
les investissements r&d qui sont liées à
ça en étant beaucoup on a beaucoup
d'investissements des temps ces domaines
là un état régalien doit investir
massivement ces technologies
c'est l'idée de ce plan et donc on nous
pour le mois soit bien très positive les
plans d'actions dans le secteur
numérique prévoit également de plancher
sur lies éducation l'hôpital numériques
ou encore les objets connectés
puisque nous sommes à l encours reste
onze y encore quelques instants avec un
tout autre sujet ce week end s'ouvre une
finale la finale du grand prix mondial
des échecs la chapelle de la commanderie
de la lutte va accueillir jusqu au 4
octobre
les douze meilleurs joueurs mondiaux les
parties se joueront chaque jour à partir
de 15 heures
l'enjeu une qualification pour le
tournoi qui permettra de se désigner le
prochain adversaire du champion du monde
en titre il ya beaucoup d'enjeux elles
deux français sont en compétition dont
le vice champion d'europe 2012
laurent frayssinet on en revient à la
politique après plus de trente ans
passés à la tête de la ville de
rambouillet gérard larcher a décidé de
passer la main le sénateur ump ne sera
pas candidat à un nouveau mandat en mars
prochain et nous l'avons rencontré lors
de son passage à magny les hameaux pour
s'en tenir à la candidate de son parti
sur cette ville aux municipales c'est
l'entretien de cette édition
gérard larcher sénateur maire ump
bonjour bonjour vous êtes avec nous pour
parler notamment de votre présence ici
pour soutenir la candidature de rohr
berger à magny les hameaux mais on va
commencer par votre actualité je disais
maire ump de rambouillet mais plus pour
très longtemps en mars vous avez décidé
de ne pas briguer un nouveau mandat
pourquoi d'abord je suis vert depuis 31
ans je pense que la responsabilité
quelqu'un comme moi c'est de préparer
l'avenir et avec le député qui est aussi
premier adjoint de rambouillet jean
frédéric poisson dans un contexte que
nous connaissons d'un texte qui est
inexorablement si j'ai entendu lu
ministre val cet après midi j'allais
dire contre l'avis d'une majorité du
sénat
eh bien on pourra pu avoir un mandat
parlementaire un mandat exécutif local
qui sera justement le successeur que
vous allez soutenir pendant cette
campagne au bia il a été choisi par
l'ensemble des élus de la majorité
municipale à l'unanimité marc robert
c'est un homme qui est consulté en
assurant un enfant de rambouillet pour
les rambos l'état ils sauront c'est un
enfant d'école de la louvière à
rambouillet et je peux vous dire que
c'est quelqu'un qui est très estimé et
apprécié quand même temps la carne aussi
j'allais dire une ardeur une ardeur
nouvelle et une énergie donc pas que je
manquais d'énergie j'étais plutôt connu
pour en avoir mais je crois que c'est
important savez amer il n'est pas le
propriétaire de sa ville
aunis mandat en fait c'est quelque chose
qu'on vous confie et la responsabilité
me semble de transmettre et préparer
cette transmission pour pas dans une
désignation est ce qui m'a réjoui c'est
que la proposition que nous avons faite
et jean frédéric poisson unanimité qui
n'est pas si fréquent dans une équipe
municipale
là pour le soutenir et puis présentera
sa propre équipe en train d anciens mais
beaucoup de nouveau avec un nouveau
projet qui certes s'inscrira dans une
forme de continuité mais ouvrira de
nouveaux horizons mais je trouve que
c'est très bien ainsi
comment vous allez vous impliquez vous
pendant cette campagne les chalets droit
rien celui qui décidera et j'allais dire
moi j'ai une relation très affective
avec les habitants en juillet vous savez
je leur ai créé une lettre et je vois
les réactions premières lettres sont
arrivées aujourd'hui et je reçois des
tas de messages
parce qu'en fait ne se connaît vraiment
chaque maison dans la ville après 30 ans
je suis un habitant de la ville pas
quelqu'un qui est qui n'est pas de liens
très profonds des enfants étaient à
l'école la battant mes petits enfants
tout petits à près d'un marché dans le
jardin à rambouillet enfin voila voila
les choses et cette ville que j'aime
profondément
elle a beaucoup de chance et laura je
crois en marc robert quelqu'un de très
bien vous allez soutenir d'autres
candidats ainsi pendant ces leçons
positives ligue en france dans les
yvelines en france parce que c'est ma
responsabilité
j'allais dire d'hommes engagés
politiquement du sénateur surtout à un
moment tout à fait important pour les
collectivités territoriales
je n'évoquerai ce soir le texte qui est
en cours de discussion qui va venir le 2
octobre c'est d'avoir bouleversé les
intercommunalités et y compris la
communauté d'agglo ici est donc face à
ce texte qui est imposée à marche forcée
comment nous allons réagir
quelles perspectives d'organisation
territoriale c'est des sujets qui
intéressent les communes qui sont aussi
des sujets majeurs
vous êtes vous satisfait du début de
campagne de l'ump globalement parce que
vous en train de dire qu'il aurait fallu
à centrer sans nous avons désigné au
plan national dans un certain nombre de
villes du nord-est ce sera début octobre
quelques-uns désigné dans les yvelines
oui on est engagée c'est parti
et j'allais dire les uns les autres mais
une élection municipale ce n'est pas
qu'une élection politique c'est le choix
d'une équipe c'est le choix d'un chef
d'equipe et ça transcende un peu les
clivages politiques c'est pour ça que
mon approche d'une élection municipale
c'est d'abord de soutenir des hommes des
femmes qui forment une équipe pour leur
territoire pour leur commune
car sinon je n'aurais jamais fait les
scores si c'était simplement une
élection politique que j'ai fait à
rambouillet depuis j'allais dire mon
premier renouvellement de mandat donc
ces scores là il montrait que des hommes
et des femmes qui n'avaient pas les
mêmes choix politiques nationaux que moi
il m'a porté un très large soutien
c'est mon état d'esprit et c'est mon
état d'esprit j'allais dire pour tout
les municipales dans les yvelines et
sens magny les hameaux
vous voyez la situation comment évaluer
comment ça je vois aurore bergé avec qui
j'ai beaucoup travaillé j'ai travaillé
quand elle été collaboratrice de la
ministre j'étais président du sénat
naturellement les tessinoises donc je
sais tu es quelqu'un avec qui nous
avions des relations je les ai vus aussi
quand j'avais la responsabilité de la
fédération
et où elle était la responsable mais
j'ai surtout vu une femme très ouverte
très libre qui n'a pas des a priori
qu'ils ne s'enferment pas dans des
conservatismes qui est plutôt pour moi
qui viens de la famille des gaullistes
sociaux quelques acquis quand tu toute
autre génération que la mienne incarne
bien les valeurs auxquelles je me trouve
très bien la question de la laïcité
aussi ces questions là ces questions où
je la sens très à l'aise en plus elle
est très intelligente elle est
volontaire elle est engagée et je crois
que une collectivité locale a besoin
d'un chef d'equipe qui soit comme ça ou
vraie dynamique et décider alors non pas
100 magny les hameaux mais peut-être sur
l'ensemble de l'hexagone quelle place
pour le front national avec l'ump avec
les dernières déclarations de françois
fillon par exemple quand des villes il
faut vous les lisiers aucune place ni
accord ni appel au vote combat contre le
front national
enfin je veux dire faut qu'on arrête
cette espèce de procès vous savez moi je
il se trouve que je suis le plus ancien
qui chemine avec rome et françois
puisque j'étais avec philippe seguin
alors vous imaginez bien que ceux qui
veulent y est par contre se poser la
question pourquoi 30 % de nos
concitoyens se disent qu'ils n'ont
aucune difficulté à voter front national
c'est que nos politiques et les partis
démocratiques
j'avais deere classic est ce qu'on
répond à la question des gens
aujourd'hui face à la crise le sentiment
d'effondrement du pays le sentiment
d'effondrement jali dans la situation en
matière de sécurité
la question de l'emploi j'étais ministre
du travail le chômage des jeunes est ce
qu'on donne de l'espérance est ce qu on
a un projet et est ce qu on fait ce
qu'on dit qu'on va faire il ya sur un
certain nombre de sujets y compris les
questions d'identité d'immigration des
réponses qu'il faut apporter ses
réponses et peuvent se faire avec nos
valeurs mais il faut qu'on ait un projet
qui soit fort j'allais dire le centre de
la vie politique
pardonnez moi c'est l'ump
c'est aussi le dialogue l'opposition que
nous avons avec les choix du parti
socialiste merci gérard larcher merci à
vous trois cent mille euros c'est ce que
coûtera la hausse de la tva au 1er
janvier au parc zoologique de thoiry une
injustice pour la famille de lapanouse
qui a fondé et qui gère cet
établissement
aujourd'hui dans une lettre ouverte au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
elle demande que le parc ne soit plus
assimilés aux loisirs de plein air comme
le sont les parcs d'attraction elle
s'interroge aussi sur cette dérogation
accordée au cirque pour qui la taxation
n'est que de 5,5 pour cent des os et des
prix les billets d'entrée pour les
particuliers mais aussi pour les
scolaires sont à attendre
faute d'une nouvelle réglementation
c'est peut-être aurez-vous à vélo cette
initiative dans un supermarché de la
verrière va donc forcément vous séduire
les clients peuvent en effet maintenant
faire leurs courses avec un chariot
dernier cri on peut y inclure des packs
d'eau des packs de lait une fois les
courses terminées il suffit d'accrocher
son panier sous la selle du vélo pour
amener et les courses à son domicile le
service est gratuit avec une caution
d'une centaine d'euros on écoute la
responsable de cette enseigne à la barre
elle est tout à fait le même principe
sauf que vous pouvez pas l'accrocher
derrière un vélo et en plus vous êtes
limités en poids avec un petit chariot
celui là vous pouvez mettre jusqu'à 30
kg il est vraiment bien renforcé vous
avez des sacs isothermes ce que n'avait
pas non plus sur un sac cabas et
classique aegon est donc là vous avez
deux sacs isothermes
qui permettent de transporter des
surgelés du frais très pratique fin de
cette édition du journal de 7,8 lecture
vient la semaine prochaine vous avez
rendez vous tout au long du week end
avec le 7-8 week end présenté par
anthony rech pour un point complet sur
vos loisirs rendez vous lundi 18h en
direct ou d'ici là sur les réseaux
sociaux excellent week end